[Musique]
évidemment je rappelle que cette séance
est retransmise en direct c'est ça sur
le site du Sénat
madame la rapporteur
mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président merci d'être là dans votre
maison
car c'est le Sénat la chambre des
collectivités
et vous en êtes l'un des éminents
représentants je crois
depuis quelques jours
j'ai mis un s à quelques donc cette
mission vous l'avez
c'est pourquoi on est là elle a commencé
le 1er mars c'est son objectif et de
rendre un rapport
fin juin coordination je piraterai le
dire avec deux autres travaux du Sénat
sur les collectivités d'une mission de
Gérard Larcher qui doit rendre un
rapport vers la mi-juin je crois je suis
même sûr
et puis d'autres travaux de la
délégation aux collectivités locales que
vous connaissez bien qui tenait
symposium la semaine dernière où
évidemment le président l'isnard était
invité et venu donc nous avons
l'habitude de vous recevoir et c'est
vraiment un plaisir simplement pour vous
dire que
cette mission a trois objectifs assez
simple apprécié l'impact des décisions
de l'État sur les finances locales
évidemment mais savoir si c'est bien
évalué en amont
parce qu'on a une vraie évaluation
essayez d'objectiver la situation
au-delà du sentiment
le sentiment d'insécurité il y a aussi
le sentiment de la norme d'État de la
même façon et enfin évidemment formuler
des recommandations c'est l'intérêt
parce que je crois que nous sommes à peu
près législateur encore
et donc c'est quand même pas mal qu'on
puisse faire des recommandations voir
si on législatives et donc voilà ce que
j'avais à vous dire en propos liminaire
madame la rapporteur
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
donc comme on vient de vous rappeler
monsieur le Président bachel vous a
évoqué les grands enjeux de notre
mission et je la remercie donc je tenais
à vous dire Monsieur le Président aligné
que cette mission est née de la volonté
de mon groupe le rassemble du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européenne donc nous souhaitons en effet
mener une réflexion sur l'impact concret
des décisions budgétaires décision
réglementaires et budgétaires de l'État
sur l'équilibre financier des
collectivités locales ce sujet me tient
à coeur et j'ai d'ailleurs interpellé le
gouvernement lors d'une question
d'actualité en novembre dernier pourquoi
un sujet parce qu'il est au cœur des
enjeux majeurs pour le Sénat
représentant représentant
constitutionnel des collectivités
territoriales
donc il y a plusieurs enjeux le premier
c'est l'évaluation des textes en amont
nous avons vu avec l'audition de
Monsieur Lambert trop souvent le
gouvernement évalue mal au moment de
l'élaboration des textes leur impact
financier sur des collectivités
territoriales les études d'impact sont
souvent insuffisantes pour ne pas dire
bâcler certaines fois la concertation
préalable avec les élus est souvent trop
limité mais quand elle a lieu déjà et un
autre de CNN doté de faible moyen et
souvent saisi en urgence
souvent cesign d'urgence par contre ne
peut pas jouer pleinement son rôle ni
lui ni aucune autre autorité ne peuvent
aujourd'hui contrôler l'objectivité et
la sincérité des études d'études
d'impact nous serons donc très attentifs
présidents dans votre point de vue
le deuxième sujet c'est l'analyse
précise de la situation dans notre
rapport nous souhaitons à partir
d'exemples concrets et récents souligner
les charges directes ou indirectes que
les décisions de l'État font peser sur
les collectivités
je pense en particulier au petites
communes dans les ressources techniques
et financières sont limitées dans le
cadre de cette mission nous
distinguerons les décisions
réglementaires et les décisions
budgétaires les décisions réglementaires
concernent les décrets et arrêtés dont
on sait qu'ils imposent des normes de
plus en plus nombreuses collectivités
locales sur ce point la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales du Sénat
vient de rendre un rapport sur
l'addiction aux normes il souligne par
exemple que le code général des
collectivités territoriales à tripler de
volume à 20 ans et dépasse de millions
de mots aujourd'hui le Sénat d'ailleurs
organisé le 16 mars dernier à
l'initiative de notre collègue Françoise
Gatel les États généraux du poids des
normes
les associations des Ludo ayant très
directement été associés et une charte
inédite d'engagement a été signalée
entre a été signée pardon entre le Sénat
et le gouvernement et j'observe un
design le rapport d'activités du cnen
que les normes réglementaires
représentent sur la seule année de 2022
un coup net de 2 milliards et demi
d'euros pour les collectivités c'est
considérable quand décision budgétaire
elle pèse à la fois sur les recettes à
la baisse et sur les dépenses à la
hausse essentiellement concentré sur les
textes législatifs de nature financière
ces décisions ont réduit année après
année la libre administration des
collectivités et leur autonomie
financière
principe pourtant consacrer notre dans
notre Constitution nous sommes donc
impatients de vous entendre sur ces
sujets d'autant que vous avez la double
casquette premier vice-président délégué
de l'AMF et président du Comité des
finances locales vous avez été monsieur
le Président destinataire d'un
questionnaire donc je serai pas plus
longue et je vous propose de vous céder
la parole avec grand plaisir alors juste
monsieur le Président
pour bien effectivement si vous pouvez à
chaque fois distinguer dans vos propos
aussi vous y arrivez mais c'est
c'est à propos évidemment
un peu ironique de ma part mais de bien
distinguer ce qui relève de l'AMF
parfois et ce qui peut relever du
président du Comité des finances locales
parce qu'on peut avoir un point de vue
de porte-parole d'un côté de l'autre
côté d'acteurs donc n'hésitez pas à nous
le dire pour juste pour nous éclairer je
veux que ça vous fera pas peur
pas vraiment monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs merci
d'abord de votre invitation à cette
audition toujours un grand moment que
d'être auditionné ça me rappelle ma
jeunesse à la fois quand j'étais
auditionné et puis ensuite quand dans ma
carrière universitaire j'étais de
l'autre côté de la table mais
votre mission est vaste
je ne voudrais pas remonter trop loin
dans le temps parce que bien évidemment
les questions que vous vous posez ne
sont pas totalement nouvelles
et on néanmoins tendance à s'aggraver
je rappelle que si l'on remonte à 2014
les collectivités territoriales ont été
très largement contributrice à l'effort
de réduction des dépenses
42 milliards
si nous actualisons en euros constant
nous serons proches de 50
c'est donc tout à fait considérable et
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi nous
disons aussi bien au Comité des finances
locales calemf que nous avons largement
fait notre part puisque malgré cet
effort de 50 milliards on va parler en
euros constant nous n'avons pas vu le
sentiment quand nous regardons les
contes de l'État que cela les ai
amélioré notablement
et donc ma première remarque sera d'être
étonnée que l'on puisse continuer à nous
demander de participer financièrement au
redressement des comptes publics car
personne ne l'a autant fait que les
collectivités territoriales dans leur
ensemble pas seulement les communes mais
en tant que président du Comité des
finances locales vous le savez il y a
toutes les strates de collectivités
territoriales et il y a même les
parlementaires qui siègent bien entendu
au Comité des finances locales c'est
donc un lieu j'allais dire de grandes
recherches d'harmonie dans les positions
qui sont prises lorsque nous sont soumis
les textes financiers puisque c'est
d'ailleurs la seule vraie prérogative du
Comité des finances locales
tout texte
portant des pensions recettes des
collectivités doivent faire l'objet d'un
examen par le CFL
nous avons derrière ce bilan global
[Musique]
quelques inquiétudes et nous l'avons
d'ailleurs dit récemment à la première
ministre et antérieurement à quelques
ministres parce que nous rencontrent
avec les membres du gouvernement sont
évidemment
très constants mais cela va de soi et
c'est naturel
quand on voit que le ministre de
l'économie avait évoqué une revue des
dépenses publiques ce qui nous paraît
tout à fait d'ailleurs naturel mais
qu'il avait formulé en disant et
notamment pour les collectivités
territoriales nous avons évidemment été
conduits à lui rappeler que la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales étaient un principe
constitutionnel que bien entendu cela se
situait dans le cadre de la loi mais que
justement nous tenions à ce que ça soit
respecté
donc ça c'est pour les événements
récents mais en même temps avec un coup
de rétro
pour bien voir comment les choses ont
évolué sur ces dernières années
il y a tellement de sujets que bon je
vais partir j'allais dire du dernier
la dernière loi de finances si vous le
voulez bien
parce que on a parfois le sentiment ça
va me donner aussi l'occasion de dire
cela qu'il y a des opérations des
informations
dont l'auteur se situerait l'auteur les
auteurs parce que je ne pense pas qu'il
n'y en a qu'un se situerait à Bercy on
nous sort régulièrement des chiffres qui
ne montent pas d'étonner
systématiquement les mers c'est-à-dire
que trop souvent vous parliez
de fiabilité de l'information je ne dis
pas que les informations qui sont
données ne sont pas viables mais je vous
donnerai d'ailleurs un exemple assez
parlant d'ailleurs puisque ce matin je
préside lcfl où nous avons eu deux
décrets aucun on a d'ailleurs été
vivement approuvé
mais j'aurais l'occasion vraiment d'être
in vivo si vous me permettez cette
expression c'est-à-dire pas seulement
dans les théories mais ce matin on a vu
à délibérer sur deux décrets dans un qui
n'est pas moindre celles degré sur la
CVA bien bon il y a un autre sur et un
autre sur des exonérations
supplémentaires de taxe foncière en
matière d'amélioration de l'isolation
etc
ce qui est tout à fait intéressant et
important mais dans les deux cas ce sont
les collectivités qui sont mises bien
entendu à la
en difficulté financière donc je reviens
au budget 203
il y a plusieurs faits marquants bien
entendu
le premier c'est l'anneau d'indexation
de la dotation globale de fonctionnement
ça a été une demande constante je l'ai
moi-même formulée auprès des ministres
puisque l'un de nos privilèges entre
guillemets c'est d'être les PREMIERS et
recevoir les ministres lorsque la loi de
finance
est en oeuvre et on lui avait indiqué
que ça nous paraissait pour le moins
étonnant de voir la manière dont les
choses étaient traitées
la DGF
c'est pas
une gratification
c'est pas une amabilité de la part de
l'État c'est un du
et donc un duc si l'on veut qu'elle soit
honoré doit l'être en neuroconstant
pardon de revenir sur cette notion et
quand on voit que ce alors on nous a dit
c'est extraordinaire c'est là que je
parle un peu de présentation fallacieuse
c'est extraordinaire qu'à sa fait
maintenant une douzaine d'années qu'il
n'y a pas eu d'augmentation de la DGF ce
qui est vrai ce qui est vrai sauf que
derrière cette assertion il faut
comparer bien entendu la stabilité alors
il y a eu des régressions de la DGF j'ai
d'ailleurs dit à l'époque ce que j'en
pensais bien que ça soit des gens qui
m'était proches qui l'ait mis en oeuvre
mais j'ai été très clair et donc c'est
l'avantage que j'ai c'est que j'ai
toujours tenu la même position quelle
que soit les majorités et
[Musique]
la stabilité qu'on nous vantait sur les
sur le dernier quinquennat je veux dire
quand vous avez moins de 1% d'inflation
la stabilité même en macroéconomie peut
s'entendre même si je le rappelle on
nous a déstabilisés chaque année et il y
avait plus de la moitié des
collectivités qui voyaient régresser
leur dotation globale de fonctionnement
cette la dénoncé bien entendu on s'est
exprimé sur le sujet de nombreuses
reprises mais c'était moins grave que
d'avoir
1,76% cette année avec 7,1% d'inflation
ça devait 7,1 c'est le chiffre 2022 bien
entendu il y a des estimations sur ce
que sera le chiffre 2023 qui va rue
d'ailleurs deux semaines en semaine on
verra à la fin de l'année ce qu'il en
sera mais en tout cas sur 2022 où il n'y
avait eu aucun rattrapage d'aucune
nature nous avons perdu en terme de
pouvoir d'action je peux pas faire par
les pouvoirs d'action que de pouvoir
d'achat en matière de pouvoir d'action
nous avons perdu 7,1%
en macroéconomique ce qui est indéniable
et quand on nous dit pour l'année à
venir que nous avons droit à
1,76%. alors que nous savons les uns et
les autres que probablement actuellement
elle navigue entre 5 et demi et 6-2
suivant les semaines l'inflation bon
espérons que ça restera autour de ces
chiffres mais personne ne peut le
garantir ça veut dire qu'en tout état de
cause avec un 76 nous aurions déjà dû
avoir à éponger les 7,1 plus les 5 ou 6
qui seront les chiffres de l'année 2023
potentiellement sauf miracle qui nous
permet de trouver d'un seul coup une
chute brutale de l'inflation ce que nous
appelons de nos vœux donc je veux dire
d'abord premier point c'est
effectivement la DGF
nous considérons qu'il n'y a pas le
respect de la parole républicaine
puisque je le redis parce qu'il faut
toujours y insister les noms
connaisseurs entre guillemets croient
que c'est une dotation au sens le plus
plat du terme non c'est le remboursement
de suppression d'impôts de compensation
de
transfert de charges qui se sont
entassées au fil au fil des années je
vais pas vous refaire toute la
généalogie de tout cela nous avons
essayé de l'étudier et nous avons
d'ailleurs une frise dans le cadre de
l'Observatoire des finances et de la
gestion publique locale que je préside
par ailleurs qui rappelle toutes les
grandes étapes sur les 30 dernières
années de la Décentralisation et des
effets de la décentralisation donc il y
a c'est aussi pour dire déjà des
objectifs
objectifs de la situation à travers
l'Observatoire des Finances qui est bien
entendu à coller au com ité des finances
locales je rappelle parce que c'est un
outil et un outil dont nous souhaitons
le développement j'y reviendrai l'autre
point sur lequel je veux
m'apesantir c'est évidemment la
suppression de la CVA
je veux dire je ne suis pas là pour
discuter du bien fondé de faire j'allais
dire une faveur aux entreprises
ça serait un autre débat je ne veux pas
m'élever au-dessus de ma situation
personnelle
par contre ce qui peut engendrer
critique de ma part me semble-t-il à bon
escient c'est que les tas à chaque fois
qu'il veut faire un cadeau fiscal à une
catégorie de la population le fait avec
l'argent des collectivités locales
je rappelle
ça pouvait s'entendre là aussi la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation même
si je pense que avoir des citoyens qui
ne payent plus aucun impôts n'est pas
sur le plan républicain de bonne manière
mais bon et puis maintenant c'est
vers les entreprises que ce tour de le
gouvernement en disant on va vous faire
une faveur très honnêtement en tant que
élu je n'ai pas vu d'entreprises qui
soient venu me dire que la CVAE était
leur préoccupation majeure
bien
ça a été fait sauf qu'on constate
aujourd'hui que
le remboursement n'est pas l'euro près
d'ailleurs de la matinée puisque je vous
l'ai dit on nous présentait ce matin le
décret d'application
je peux détailler je vais mais bon
quelques mots parce que je veux pas être
long mais détailler j'ai passé une
partie de ma matinée là-dessus donc j'ai
tout ça frais à l'esprit
en définitive
on nous retire je rappelle et vous le
savez tous évidemment que la CVAE a déjà
été payé à l'état
puisque c'est payé en 2022 pour être
versé en 2023 donc les chiffres sont
précis ces 11,3 milliards nous attend
répété ce matin bon donc les chiffres
sont censés être ceux qu'on nous a
indiqué ce matin c'est la DG FIP qui
nous a donné ce chiffre on le
connaissait déjà un peu alors pas 100
millions près parce que
c'est l'épaisseur du prêt du trait
disent les budgétaires mais là dessus on
nous prend 600 millions pour la part dit
dynamique
puisqu'il y a un socle
autour de 10 milliards je vais arrondir
il y a 600 millions pour la part dit
dynamique je reviendrai sur la manière
dont il envisage et puis ensuite il y a
des ponctions
puisque on nous a ponctionné 500
millions
qui est censé abonder le fond vert
puisqu'on a annoncé le fond vert à 2
milliards mais déjà sur le milliard et
demi je rappelle qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de fois existants en
particulier le fond friche mais aussi
quelques autres qui ont été recyclés
dans le fond vert
et on a ajouté pour faire bonne mesure
500 millions prix sur la CBR
à cela on a ajouté une autre ponction de
150 millions pour les 10
c'était tout à fait utile après les
grands incendies qu'on a connu
l'été dernier il avait été d'ailleurs
dit qu'il fallait vraiment renforcer les
investissements dans ce domaine mais
c'est un état qui disait il faut un
grand plan de national et nous sommes
très surpris évidemment qu'une nouvelle
fois le grand plan national soit financé
sur des ponctions de crédit qui auraient
dû revenir au collectivités
territoriales c'est pas la seule fois je
me souviens une année quand il y a eu la
tempête sur Saint-Martin
solidarité nationale
il faut bien entendu qu'on vienne en
aide à Saint-Martin et tout le monde la
main sur le cœur était de cet avis moi
le premier sauf jusqu'au moment où on a
découvert que les 50 millions pour la
reconstruction de Saint-Martin était
pris sur la légère
je me permets de vous rappeler ça
bien je vais pas vous raconter toutes
les anecdotes mais quand
oui mais là vous risqueriez d'y passer
bon
volontiers aucun souci bon non mais
quand vous me dites
la sincérité des
démarches financières de l'État à
travers quelques exemples certains plus
anciens d'autres tours récents je veux
dire on peut quand même se poser
quelques questions sur la sincérité
alors je répète on nous a dit ça par
exemple ce matin on nous a dit mais vous
inquiétez pas vous avez tout
en ce qui concerne la CV e puisque vous
avez les 10 milliards du socle les 600
millions de
la partie active
voilà et puis les
650 millions qui sont distribués
bien alors c'est vrai quand on
additionne on a l'impression qu'il y a
tout sauf que les collectivités
territoriales elles ne vont pas tous
recevoir d'abord parce que les 150
millions de 10 je répète ils en avaient
sans doute besoin mais dès l'instant où
c'était un grand plan national pourquoi
le prendre sur des crédits dédiés aux
collectivités et quant au 500 millions
qui viennent intégrer le fond vert moi
je ne sais pas mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs si dans vos départements vous
savez quel est l'enveloppe du fond vert
de votre département comment il sera
réparti en fonction de quels critères
aujourd'hui
moi je veux dire je vais un dialogue
très fructueux avec mon préfet quelqu'un
de bien dans tous les sens du terme
forcément préfet mais
toutes les autres ils misent à part je
veux dire il m'a dit je suis comme vous
j'attends voilà donc si dans certains de
vos départements ça va plus vite c'est
bien on s'en réjouit mais aujourd'hui le
fond vert je rappelle qu'on avait
demandé par exemple pour la transparence
que le fond vert fasse l'objet d'un avis
comme c'est le cas de la DETR
dans le cadre des commissions DETR
chaque département est doté d'une
commission DETR qui associe le
parlementaires les conseillers
départementaux et dont les représentants
des communes sont et des
intercommunalités sont élus sont élus
par l'ensemble des maires et présidents
d'intercommunalités du département donc
une instance tout à fait démocratique
qui a l'expérience et on avait demandé
je répète on ne donne que des avis y
compris en DETR bon console travaillait
bien faire avec un préfet qui connaît le
terrain en général ça se passe bien et
on arrive à se mettre d'accord il peut y
avoir des exceptions bien entendu mais
au moins il y a un dialogue il y a un
débat on sait pourquoi tel choix a été
fait pourquoi tel autre projet n'a pas
été retenu on peut le contester mais en
tout cas c'est clair là en ce qui
concerne la dotr c'est d'ailleurs vrai
pour les anciennes de la DS
puisque tout cela est décédé au niveau
des
préfectures de régions qui est quand
même dans un certain brouillard pour ne
pas dire un brouillard certes donc voilà
j'allais dire quelques exemples sur des
événements
immédiat présent qui continue bien sûr
on découvre qu'on nous explique que la
situation des collectivités
territoriales est excellente parce que
nous avons de la trésorerie
d'abord il faudrait
non c'est ce que dit le ministère des
Finances
oui oui je vous renvoie aux déclarations
récentes où on nous explique d'ailleurs
j'ai employé
ah oui oui je veux dire l'avantage de
même que je suis l'auteur chaque année
du rapport de l'Observatoire sur les
finances locales ce sont des chiffres
partagés avec l'État donc personne peut
me dire que je vais inventer des
chiffres ce sont ceux qui me sont
fournis soit par la direction du budget
soit par la Direction générale des
finances publiques etc bon donc je veux
dire nous on travaille avec les chiffres
qu'on nous donne on n'a pas les moyens
nous bien entendu de refaire les
chiffres globaux qui sont ceux des
finances locales donc tout ce que je
suis en train de dire est une réalité
mais bien sûr qu'il y a de la trésorerie
mais faut regarder par strat de
population en particulier en ce qui
concerne les communes nous savons les
uns et les autres et surtout vous c'est
natrices et sénateurs qui est au contact
des mers que les petites communes et
petites n'est pas du tout dans un
département rural comme le mien
d'ailleurs quasiment il y a que des
petites communes rurales même ma petite
ville je considère que c'est une ville
rurale pour être très franc euh mais on
sait tous que dans les petites communes
je parle de la taille il y a pas de
petit maire bien sûr au contraire
souvent il y a un gros projet par mandat
il y a le projet du mandat
on le sait les uns et les autres alors
les structures plus importantes ils
peuvent avoir plus évidemment mais sur
les 32 000 communes de moins de 2000
habitants etc souvent c'est un gros
projet par mandat qu'est-ce qu'ils font
même dans ma petite ville moi c'est ce
que je fais aussi quand j'ai des gros
projets
je précise
sinon j'arrive pas à monter le
financement pour un projet relativement
important au niveau de ma ville c'est
les projets au-dessus d'un million mais
pour une petite commune c'est souvent
100000 euros ou 200000 euros bon et donc
s'ils ne font pas du pré-financement
donc je veux dire ça n'a strictement
aucun sens strictement j'ajouterai à
cela que dans les temps que nous
connaissons il y a aussi de l'épargne de
précaution
et ça ne paraît pas totalement incongru
d'avoir cette épargne de précaution
quand on voit les mouvements
erratiques des dépenses de nos
collectivités territoriales et bien
entendu nous sommes frappés de plein
fouet par l'inflation je ne vais pas
vous le redire parce que je suppose que
vous l'entendrez de toute part mais je
suis prêt à répondre et puis comme je
veux plutôt répondre je vais pas être
beaucoup plus long dans mon introduction
simplement dire
les deux sujets de ce matin la CVAE
je veux dire bien entendu le décret
était l'application de la loi mais comme
il n'y a pas eu autour de la table
qui que ce soit pour dire que c'était
une bonne réforme
et les différentes familles politiques
sont représentées
au sein du CFL comme vous le savez
toutes et tous donc
on a voté massivement une abstention
parce que le décret en lui-même n'était
pas fautif il appliquait la loi
qui lui a décidé de voter contre ce qui
fait que résultat c'est le contre qui
l'a emporté avec une seule voix bon mais
enfin ça change rien puisque ça n'est
qu'un avis je le rappelle donc pas
dramatique enfin ça fait quand même
mauvais genre avoir un avis sur des
sujets aussi importants et quant à
l'autre décret là par contre ça a été
unanimité sur l'abstention parce que
l'objectif qui était de lutter contre
les passoires thermiques je connais pas
beaucoup d'entre nous qui puissent
considérer que ce n'est pas un bon
objectif mais quand on nous dit que ça
va allonger de 5 ans voire de 10 ans les
exonérations de taxe foncière et qu'on
sait que les exonérations de taxe
foncière sont remboursées à peine à
hauteur de 20%
de ce qu'elle devrait être pour les
collectivités territoriales on ne peut
pas accepter là aussi que chaque fois
que l'État fait un cadeau là en termes
de taxe foncière ça soit bien entendu
avec les ressources des collectivités
territoriales pour l'essentiel en gros
c'est 80% à la charge des collectivités
et 20% à la charge de la compensation
par l'État donc nous sommes en
permanence voilà je vais arrêter là dans
les exemples mais c'est simplement pour
dire aujourd'hui c'est devenu et le
rapport de mon ami Alain Lambert est
tout à fait clair dans le domaine je
viens d'ailleurs moi-même d'intégrer le
CNN
c'est surtout de l'eau supplémentaires
si vous voulez tout savoir
j'ai le génie pour avoir des postes
totalement bénévoles
ce qui est le cas
je vais pas ajouter parce qu'il y en a
d'autres bon donc
c'est vrai que ça devient
totalement gérable totalement gérable
quand vous ajoutez à cela l'inflammation
modeste ville faut que je trouve un
million 500 mille j'ai une impasse d'un
million 500 000 et ma communauté de
communes un million 900 000
j'ai pas eu de chance moi j'étais obligé
de renégocier mes tarifs d'électricité
pour le 1er janvier ceux qui ont eu la
chance de ne pas avoir à renégocier les
tarifs énergétiques évidemment
pour l'instant donc les actualisations
j'allais dire au fil de l'eau mais pour
le gaz que je dis quand même pas encore
négocié puisque ça va venir en cours
d'année 2024 c'est quand même sur
l'année 2022 plus de 35% d'augmentation
aujourd'hui c'est ça et on continue à
nous expliquer que nous sommes
vraiment très à l'aise
et que on ne voit pas pourquoi les
collectivités territoriales se plaignent
il y en a qui employé le mot de
pleureuse en ce qui concerne les élus
locaux c'est très triste des pleureuses
par nature mais je pense pas que ça soit
du tout l'objet je crains
malheureusement que la réalité soit une
réalité objective qui rend de plus en
plus difficile et cela se traduit
l'exercice du mandat de maire et cela se
traduit par un nombre sans précédent de
d'émissions alors pas seulement de maire
mais aussi d'adjoint des lieux communaux
municipaux c'est de l'ordre nous dit-on
sur le terrain on va essayer
d'objectiver parce que là aussi on nous
donne pas vraiment tous les chiffres
mais il semblerait que le nombre de
démissions à date équivalentes
c'est-à-dire ami mandat puisque nous
sommes pile à miamanda
il y a trois ans avait lieu le premier
tour des élections municipales
exactement
et nous étions d'ailleurs pour ceux qui
avaient un deuxième tour en
voilà donc je vais dire c'est vraiment
une situation très préoccupante parce
qu'il y a à la fois
ce manque de clarté
dans l'approche y compris ce matin quand
j'ai demandé
si c'était une exonération ou un
dégrèvement
il a fallu un certain temps et beaucoup
de concertations entre les représentants
de l'État pour me dire d'une petite voix
exonération
or exonération tout le monde connaît la
différence c'est que c'est très très mal
compensé c'est ce que je disais
précédemment alors qu'évidemment
dégrèvement
fait une obligation à l'état de
compenser bon mais ça savait pas été
vraiment clairement dit il a fallu que
je pose la question pour éclaircir pour
nos collègues présents soit directement
soit visioconférence la réalité de la
situation voilà je m'arrête c'est pour
donner quelqu'un exemples illustré le
propos
j'ai déjà été trop long dans mon
introduction pas du tout au contraire tu
es particulièrement intéressant et puis
vraiment plus qu'inspiré par la réalité
vu que c'est tout frais sorti du four ce
matin de la réflexion tout de suite la
parole à
rapporteur et puis je vais prendre les
interventions j'aurais moi-même quelques
questions
merci président c'était extrêmement
intéressant et tellement criant de
vérité et de des exemples très par là
tout à l'heure vous parliez de
des finances des petites collectivités
des petites communes qui sont qui sont
sur pas du tout parce que je vais vous
donner un exemple hier je recevais un
maire d'une petite commune 950 habitants
qui avait déjà mis en place loué un
local qu'il avait aménagé pour pour une
boulangerie ça marchait très très bien
puisqu'il avait agrandi il avait fait
des pizzas et puis il s'avère qu'avec la
crise énergétique de 800 euros il est
passé à 8000 euros par mois et il est
voilà il ne sait plus comment il va il
ne peut pas s'en sortir et le maire est
venu me voir à se désespéré me disant on
peut pas on ne peut pas accepter que
cette boulangerie ferme qu'est-ce que je
vais faire qu'est-ce que je peux faire
je voudrais faire des des panneaux
photovoltaïques mais il me faut monter
le dossier il me faut des financements
donc voilà c'est toujours le même le
même problème et aujourd'hui pour
arriver à 80% de financement c'est très
très compliqué
partout mais sur des toutes petites
communes aussi c'est voilà donc c'est un
exemple parmi d'autres mais voilà merci
j'aurais juste une question donc les
dotations sont devenues un outil donc
permanent permettant pardon de la
fixation de par la loi de finance du
volume global des concours financiers de
l'État aux collectivité territoriale
fonctionnement qui on le sait manque de
prévisible pardon de prévisibilité et de
visibilité seriez-vous favorables à une
nouvelle clé de répartition des impôts
nationaux stable sur plusieurs exercices
et gage d'une meilleure anticipation
pour les exécutifs locaux par exemple
on va d'abord apprendre comme vous
voulez
je suis la commission des finances donc
la commission des finances on répond
d'abord aux rapporteur général donc la
rapporteur et puis après les questions
seront ouvertes c'est c'est de tradition
c'est une maison de tradition et je
m'incline forcément devant ces
traditions
d'abord un mot sur l'impact de
l'inflation je veux dire moi je ne peux
quasiment pas rencontrer de mère qui
n'est pas de difficulté à boucler son
budget et Bercy continue à nous
expliquer qu'il y a aucun problème
alors j'avoue que je suis en permanence
soit
on nous globalise les choses sans qu'on
sache très bien ce qui est dans la
globalité donc quelqu'un on peut
toujours faire des démonstrations au
tableau blanc ou noir peu importe sa
couleur
soit on nous balade pardon de cette
expression facile
j'ai plutôt le sentiment que c'est la
deuxième explication qui est la bonne
parce qu'on a bon à expliquer on a bon
je veux dire lors de la rencontre que
nous avons eu récemment en délégation de
la MF avec la première ministre et
quelques ministres qu'ils l'entouraient
je lui avais dit mais madame la Première
ministre
Bercy continuait à expliquer que les
collectivités territoriales sont assises
sur un tas d'or
d'abord c'est très inconfortable je
suppose
mais surtout comment peut-on dire des
choses comme ça moi je veux dire vous
êtes sur le terrain vous rencontrez vos
élus locaux est-ce qu'il y en a qui vous
disent et tant mieux il doit bien y en
avoir sur les 35000 34000 et quelques
qui disent boîte tout va bien bon je ne
vais pas statistiquement dire que ça
n'est pas possible mais je sais pas si
vous en rencontrez beaucoup d'ailleurs
ça m'intéresserait que vous me disiez
mais si dans mon département
l'immense majorité des maires n'a pas de
difficulté à boucler son budget bon moi
j'ai un peu d'expérience je vous
rappelle que je suis tombé du dernier
wagons mais
je veux dire jamais je n'ai connu une
situation
équivalente jamais
je veux dire il y avait des années plus
difficiles que d'autres là c'est pas une
année difficile
c'est quasiment une année impossible
or nous le ferons quand même
puisque nous sommes tenus à l'équilibre
donc nous le ferons mais avec
quelle réduction des services publics
locaux
c'est ça la question moi je veux dire je
vais fermer ma piscine bon j'ai fermé ma
patinoire ces dernières semaines parce
que je n'ai eu les résultats de mon
appel d'offre qu'en janvier bon mais
j'ai pris immédiatement certains nombre
de mesures j'allais dire mais sont des
fermetures provisoire j'espère bien
pouvoir réouvrir mais il faut d'abord
que je sois capable d'équilibrer mes
budgets puisque je préside aussi la
communauté de la communauté de la ville
or aujourd'hui je ne sais pas le faire
et comme nous avons de moins en moins et
je viens à votre question que je n'ai
pas oublié sur les impôts nationaux
comme nous avons de moins en moins de
maîtrise des impôts
je veux dire forcément nous dit oh ça va
cogner je reprends les expressions qu'on
entend sur la taxe foncière mais
attendez sur quoi voulez-vous qu'on a
juste nos budgets puisque c'est
maintenant le sol impôt sur lequel on
peut ajuster alors il y a un peu de CFE
un peu mais enfin massivement c'est le
foncier on a pas d'autres possibilités
et c'est pour ça que moi je ne suis pas
favorable dans un pot nationaux pour les
collectivités territoriales la MEF non
plus d'ailleurs quand je dis moi pardon
de cette appropriation d'une idée
collective
nous ce que nous souhaitons c'est que
chaque niveau de collectivité c'est à
dire commune
bien sûr département et régions et un
impôt
S et nous sommes pour l'universalité de
la peau c'est à dire que nous sommes
pour que tous citoyens payent l'impôt ça
peut être 10 euros
pour les plus en difficulté
pour être le rôle symbolique même c'est
pas la question bien mais je veux dire
être citoyen
c'est aussi participer
et malheureusement plus on déconnecte
les citoyens et maintenant les
entreprises
de l'impôt local
plus on a affaire à des gens qui peuvent
tout réclamer puisqu'on ne peut pas leur
dire ensuite bah d'accord mais est-ce
que tu es prêt à ce que tes impôts
augmentent avant c'était un argument
qu'on avait
de bons droits en disant bah écoute oui
ben ça ça va coûter ça est-ce que si je
programme une augmentation d'impôts de
la taxe d'habitation du foncier peu
importe tu es d'accord dès l'instant où
la finalité c'est ce que tu me proposes
ça permettait un dialogue un dialogue
républicain et aujourd'hui on peut tout
nous réclamer
puisque la plupart ne payent plus du
tout bien donc non nous ne sommes pas
pour des impôts nationaux
de même que on nous explique évidemment
la TVA c'est une manne absolument
fabuleuse
et ce matin leur présentant de la DGFiP
a eu une phrase mais ce n'était pas
volontaire en disant vous comprenez ça
vous garantit pour
quasiment l'éternité des ressources
évolutives j'ai simplement rappeler
gentiment que l'éternité s'appelait la
dualité budgétaire
ce qui fait une éternité quand même très
courte
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président je vais
passer aux questions des uns et des
autres Olivier nos épuisé le briquet se
prépare merci monsieur le Président
c'est le président vous
votre exposé était très claire et je
vous en remercie notamment sur le l'état
des finances des collectivités vous avez
partiellement abordé cette question mais
je voudrais que vous puissiez aller un
peu plus loin sur la question de
l'autonomie fiscale des collectivités
territoriales vous êtes un peu enfin ou
tout au moins vous étiez au coeur de la
réflexion un des pères de la
décentralisation au fond en
1982 et donc quel est votre vision
est-ce que vous avez une idée sur la la
part d'autonomie fiscale pour que une
qui est une véritable décentralisation
et deuxièmement est-ce que au fond à
partir du moment où l'autonomie fiscale
est à ce point réduit évidemment
maintenant je ne suis plus maire moi
avec le nom cumule mais à l'époque
lorsque j'ai été lumière en 2001 et il y
avait la TH
il y avait évidemment la taxe
professionnelle encore il y avait pas
été transféré à l'interco ou à la
métropole il y avait le foncier bâti il
y avait la TH bah aujourd'hui déjà il y
a plus que foncier bâti et foncier non
bâti mais dans des communes un peu
urbaines c'est très peu bon donc est-ce
que il peut encore y avoir une
décentralisation de projet à partir du
moment où l'autonomie fiscale est aussi
faible et donc est-ce que derrière les
les démissions nombreuses que vous avez
évoquées et dont on a des des chiffres
aussi il y a pas aussi cette idée que
pour reprendre une expression qui a déjà
été exprimée on est c'est beaucoup moins
intéressant pour les élus locaux si on
est dans une décentralisation
d'exécution plutôt que dans une
décentralisation de projet je vous
remercie
désolé
merci
président donc monsieur le Président le
Niel
quelques petites questions la première
c'est j'aimerais bien avoir votre votre
avis puisqu'on a beaucoup parlé de
normes et puis c'est le but de cette de
cette de cette mission sur les votre
vision sur les normes contradictoires
on a tous une expérience de mère et moi
je me suis beaucoup frotter la tête pour
pas dire plus entre les normes imposants
les normes de sécurité et les normes
d'accessibilité je trouve à un moment si
je faisais la sécurité je pouvais pas
faire l'accessibilité et inversement
donc au bout d'un moment on a les fils
qui se touchent donc voilà ça c'est un
premier point mais de
issu de mon expérience personnelle là il
y a des moments ça a été compliqué
c'était soit l'un soit l'autre mais les
deux en même temps moi j'ai des endroits
où j'ai pas su faire et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure c'est sur un point
complètement différent sur la fâcheuse
tendance de de faire financer ces
annonces par par les collectivités on a
vu
la TH la CVAE vous avez parlé du 10
aussi tout à l'heure tout ceci ce sont
des des annonces que finance les
collectivités et ça revient à la
question de l'autonomie financière des
collectivités et quand on voit le
dernier rapport de la Cour des comptes
sur lequel nous allons débattre demain
après-midi et où certains d'entre nous
vont d'ailleurs intervenir où on peut
partager certains constats émis par la
cour mais où il est aussi avancé la
nécessaire diminution du nombre de
communes faisant état de son nombre trop
importants d'une autre importante de ces
collectivités dans notre beau pays et on
voit bien que le remplacement de des
ressources propres par des dotations et
étant le levier pour un pour justifier
en les asséchant financièrement pour
supprimer cette échel on de pourtant de
proximité et particulièrement
indispensable ainsi qu'on puis le
démontrer les cris successives s'il n'y
avait pas eu les communes des élus les
élus communaux pour prendre les choses à
main on sait pas trop comment on s'y
serait pris donc j'aimerais bien avoir
votre avis à ce sujet merci
Viviane Artigas oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Laignel
merci aussi de votre présence et puis de
votre exposé très intéressant moi je
voudrais venir sur deux points sur la
question d'abord effectivement de cette
rumeur qui court mais c'est trop facile
que les communes ont beaucoup de
trésorerie elles ont beaucoup d'argent
très globalement sans voir
qu'effectivement il y a une quand même
une grande différence moi je sais pas
comment on peut arriver à faire
comprendre quand même aussi que la
trésorerie ça fait des fonds propres des
fonds propres qui servent à faire des
investissements et des investissements
qui font marcher l'économie locale donc
bon on est là sur un cercle vertueux je
dirais qui fait qu'à un moment donné les
collectivités locales au delà de ça
c'est de la vie sur nos territoires nos
communes c'est de la vie sur nos
territoires c'est de l'emploi c'est de
l'économie chaque fois qu'il y a des
crises dans les finances locales et bien
on voit les fédérations du Bâtiment qui
viennent nous voir en nous disant mais
nous on va passer une année on sait bien
que la commande publique même des
éléments importants qui fait vivre nos
entreprises ça c'est le premier point
comment faut-il faire pour arriver à
faire comprendre ça à nos ministres et
ça rejoint la question qui effectivement
chaque petite commune et utile sur ce
sujet et on a l'impression que je
rejoins un petit peu Isabelle en a quand
même l'impression que toutes ces normes
parfois et je peut-être que je suis un
peu trop paranoïaque mais que c'est
normes et ces contraintes budgétaires se
sont faits pour mettre en volontairement
en difficulté les communes pour
effectivement réduire leur montre et
leur nombre et diminuer leur possibilité
d'action la deuxième c'est sûr comment
pourrait-on faire parce qu'à un moment
donné dans les transferts de charge on
évalue toujours pas avec les claettes
que ce soit dans les transferts de
charge à l'intercommunalité mais que ça
soit aussi les transferts de décharge de
l'État aux collectivité lors de
différentes lois de décentralisation on
évalue le coût de la de la compétence à
intenté or on sait très bien que dans le
temps cette compétence le de la
compétence pardon je pense la compétence
scolaire pour les les régions les
collèges ou les communes ou parfois les
intercommunalités maintenant entre le
moment où on a pris la compétence et le
moment et le tenter ou d'aujourd'hui la
compétence et la parfois doublée
financièrement ou triplés ou voire même
multiplié par 10 donc comment
et on nous dit c'est la loi c'est la
décentralisation donc vous finissez dans
c'est ça sur l'Impôt sur l'impôt local
sauf que maintenant nous n'avons plus
d'impôts d'impôts local donc cette
augmentation progressive de décentralise
afin de transfert de compétences de
l'État vers les régions qui ont lu il y
a un moment comment voterait-il faire
bon je sais qu'il y a des on travaille à
la MF un petit peu sur sur ce sujet avec
l'idée d'un moment donné d'avoir une
clause de revoyure pour revoir un petit
peu alors c'est un petit peu la même
chose pour l'inflation c'est mais c'est
plutôt là sur effectivement à cause de
l'inflation aussi à cause d'autres
choses une compétence
la compétence scolaire par exemple avec
le les agents publics qui qui le point
d'indice ça augmente là par des
décisions de l'État donc comment faut-il
faire pour qu'il y ait des clauses de
revoyure à des moments sur ces questions
là de de d'augmentation du coût du
transfert de compétences de l'État alors
qui nous suppriment nos notre fiscalité
dynamique
merci Viviane alors j'ai rajouté
quelques questions mais qui sont du même
ordre finalement en résumant c'est
est-ce que vous êtes pour une indexation
ou pour une clause de revoyure ce qui
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose mais
est-ce que c'est une indexation
automatique par exemple ou une clôture
deuxième niveau de question c'est
félicitations pour votre ça m'avait
échappé j'ai honte
pour votre nom le président du cnen la
Lambert nous a dit
il pourrait on pourrait réfléchir à
l'intégration du CNN dans le CFL
qu'en pensez-vous
par ailleurs dans les compétences de la
cnen comme du CFF
alors c'est tout ça est très consultatif
aujourd'hui
faut-il passer à autre chose que le
consultatif
et c'est un peu un consultatif excenté
comme pour le Conseil d'État si vous
voulez comme vous avez présenté un texte
en premier ministre
ou est-ce qu'il faut voilà c'est une
fois que la loi est passée on vous
informe simplement que ça va passer donc
est-ce que c'est une information
finalement ou une vraie consultation ou
un pouvoir de dire non peut-être un
objection potentiel peut-être c'est des
suggestions d'amendement avant que ça
passe en CFF
notre niveau de questions 3e niveau de
question c'est sur les tarifs
parce que nous avons effectivement les
impôts locaux et ça on a bien vu qu'on
en avait plus
et une des façons d'équilibrer vous
venez de le dire monsieur le Président
c'est évidemment la taxe foncière vu
qu'il reste plus que ça avec toujours
une liaison des taux derrière ce qui est
ce qui peut être un sujet est-ce que
vous êtes pour la délinaison des taux
pour donner un peu de liberté
même si on a pu beaucoup des impôts mais
enfin la délision ça reste quand même
sur important pour plein de choses à
THRs etc
ils ont des taux mais vous avez aussi
sur les compétences non obligatoires
vous faites payer votre compte ou pas
c'est une décision votre piscine elle
est gratuite ou il y a un ticket
modérateur on va dire ça là comme cela
est-ce que c'est pas aussi le risque de
l'inflation
fait porter sur les collectivités sur
toutes les compétences optionnelles par
les tarifs donc est-ce que finalement la
norme d'État elle est aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus la main sur les recettes
et sur les dépenses c'est la norme qui
arrive
non merci
j'espère que j'oublierai rien mais vous
me rappeler alors parce que j'ai pris
quelques notes mais il y avait
énormément évidemment de questions et de
sujets dans vos différentes
interventions
il y a une question qui est revenue à
plusieurs reprises
ou un mot qui est toute une question
c'est le mot autonomie
je rappelle qu'il y a deux sujets en ce
qui concerne l'autonomie on pourrait en
imaginer d'autres mais dans le débat qui
est le nôtre c'est l'autonomie
financière d'un côté l'autonomie fiscal
de l'autre ce sont de choses différentes
parce que tout cela
je rappelle que aujourd'hui là je vais
faire mon ex prof de droit aujourd'hui
dans la Constitution il n'y a que
l'autonomie financière
qui a été en plus totalement détourné de
son sujet par la loi organique
puisque aujourd'hui vous pouvez avoir
des dotations totalement à la main de
l'État qui sont considérés comme
néanmoins nourrissant l'autonomie
ce qui n'était pas j'allais dire l'idée
des constituants qui avait introduit
cette notion dans la Constitution je me
permets de rappeler ça et déjà il y
aurait un immense progrès si l'on
voulait bien refaire une loi organique
qui donne une définition réelle de
l'autonomie il y a autonomie quand on
peut décider le taux
ou l'assiette
et si possible le taux et l'assiette
si on ne peut décider d'aucun des deux
où est l'autonomie
je laisse la question à votre sagacité
collective donc ça c'est un premier
sujet le deuxième sujet c'est la bien
entendu l'autonomie fiscale jusque là
nous la réclamons déjà depuis un certain
temps quand je dis nous c'est aussi bien
d'ailleurs le CFL que l'Association des
maires de France est beaucoup d'autres
bien
malheureusement pour l'instant nous ne
sommes pas entendus c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est même très exactement
l'inverse qui se produit puisque on nous
dépouille
de la plupart des impôts dans la durée
il y a eu effectivement la taxe
professionnelle c'est déjà beaucoup plus
ancien dans les années 2000 mais bon
maintenant on arrive
passez-moi l'expression on arrive à l'os
il reste plus grand chose
à la moelle bon si vous voulez il reste
plus grand chose à retirer bien et
d'ailleurs on voit déjà toutes les
campagnes qui se profilent en disant
regardez tous ces élus irresponsables
qui sont en train de matraquer le
foncier
et bien entendu l'étape suivante c'est
de supprimer le foncier
dans l'esprit de certains
pendant pas dans le mien mais dans
l'esprit de certains on le voit bien ça
se profile et certains ça peut être bien
entendu certains groupes de pression de
propriétés immobiliers ils sont dans le
rôle de dire des choses bien je ne
critique absolument pas leur liberté de
parole mais quand c'est aussi du côté
des institutions qu'on entend le même
refrain là ça devient beaucoup plus
inquiétant donc je veux dire
là aussi ce que nous réclamons nous
c'est que l'autonomie fiscale souhaite
introduite aux côtés de l'autonomie
financière dans la Constitution on nous
parle n'est-ce pas nous parler il y a
quelques temps de réforme
des institutions à nouveau une somme que
le Président de la République nous parle
de réformes constitutionnelle c'est
d'ailleurs un curieux moment pour
évoquer ce sujet mais ça c'est une
réflexion pardon là je me suis élevé en
dehors de mes responsabilités c'est le
citoyen qui parlait
merci merci monsieur le Président
mais c'est vrai très franchement que
évoquer la réforme constitutionnelle
quand le pays dans l'état que nous
connaissons peut quand même paraître
pour le moins à tout petit peu à côté
des sujets principaux même si bien
entendu nous avons nombreuses
propositions à faire en matière de
réforme constitutionnelle d'ailleurs
nous les avons présentés nous les avons
présenté à tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle enfin ceux qui
sont venus
puisque il y en a un qui est pas venu
bon donc évidemment la notion de
dialogue perd un peu de son charme dans
ces cas-là
donc oui c'est un vrai sujet que
l'autonomie financière est fiscale et on
peut se poser la question il y a-t-il et
d'ailleurs elle a été posée par l'un
d'entre vous peut-il y avoir des
centralisation s'il n'y a pas cette
autonomie nécessaire
j'ai tendance à considérer que la
dépendance au dotation est en réalité la
forme la plus vicieuse de tutelle
tout ce que je dis ici est forcément par
nature publique et publiable
général je pèse mes mots ça m'a valu par
le passé quelques déboires parce que
j'ai eu quelques formules célèbres
détournées d'ailleurs de leur objet
parce que sinon ça serait pas drôle tu
défrases célèbre voilà mais bon c'est
déjà bien d'en avoir une
au moins au moins bon mais pour revenir
au sujet toutes les autres et mis à part
bien entendu tout cela
pose de vraies questions et
je crois pas que tu sois pardon madame
la sénatrice que vous soyez paranoïaque
quand vous subodorez qu'un certain
nombre de choses puissent conduire
certains à penser que il y a trop de
communes et que la commune elle-même
d'ailleurs était encore nécessaire
bien entendu vous l'aurez compris ce
n'est pas du tout notre position mais je
sais bien mais
c'est tout le charme de la Cour des
comptes là je suis très prudent dans mes
propos tout le charme de la Cour des
comptes c'est-à-dire que c'est une
grande institution mais qui parfois se
regarde dans le miroir plutôt que dans
l'avenir
et l'idée qu'il y aurait trop de
communes en France est une
erreur fondamentale aujourd'hui
quel est le grand mot de notre société
c'est le sentiment de beaucoup de nos
concitoyens d'être déclassés
et souvent leur premier recours mais
aussi parfois leur dernier espoir c'est
le maire la commune
et vouloir éloigner
du citoyen le lieu de la décision de sa
vie quotidienne et sans doute ce qui
peut le plus
conduire aux extrêmes
en ce qui concerne
les investissements parce qu'on nous dit
vous êtes riche puis regarder il y a
plus d'investissements de 2022
qu'en 2020
l'argument est pour le moins là aussi
spéciaux car
c'est un effet réel mais de rattrapage
quand
j'ai été élu maire en 2020 bien entendu
mon budget était déjà voté parce que moi
je vote toujours mes budgets en décembre
sauf cette année là c'est un peu
compliqué mais bon en tout cas pour la
ville puis comme c'est des services
mutualisés la communauté c'est début
janvier pour que les services et le
temps de faire les deux budgets mais moi
quand j'ai voté mon budget en 2020
évidemment que j'avais prévu les
investissements que
Bruxelles même le débat de campagne que
de dire voilà ce que je prévois voilà ce
qu'on a mis au budget 2020 pour amorcer
la nouvelle mandature
débat normal dans ces périodes sauf que
sa pas pu être réalisée en 2020 mais
c'était déjà financé
puisque le budget lui avait été voté en
2021 n'était pas encore au creux de la
crise on a aussi rebudgété un certain
nombre d'investissements qui n'ont pas
pu se faire immédiatement puisque ce
2020 n'avait déjà pas été intégralement
mis en œuvre compte tenu de la pandémie
compte tenu que beaucoup d'entreprises
étaient à l'arrêt compte tenu qu'on
n'avait pas forcément les matières les
matières premières etc etc donc oui 2022
a été une année de rattrapage et donc
c'est vrai parce qu'on nous dit regardez
en 2022 les investissements ont augmenté
de près de 10%
oui alors ils avaient baissé tellement
plus antérieurement
et en plus en 2022 il y a déjà le début
du commencement de l'inflation qui fait
que là aussi
si on ne raisonne pas en euros constant
on n'a pas une Clairvision des choses en
2023 nous risquons d'avoir un
investissement qui va être gonflé par
l'inflation
mais qui en réalité
recouvrera beaucoup moins
d'investissements en tant coopération
que par le passé donc là aussi et puis
même sur 2023 moi j'ai encore des prêts
financement d'attente 2021-2022 qui vont
se réaliser en 2023 par contre ma grande
inquiétude c'est 2024 parce que quand
mes budgets 2023 je vais baisser
drastiquement mon autofinancement et
donc ma capacité d'investissement c'est
en 2024 que ça trouvera en réalité sa
répercussion donc faisons attention
j'allais dire aux fausses fenêtres aux
faux semblant que l'on peut avoir dans
les chiffres globaux qui nous sont
donnés donc oui on a le sentiment que
[Musique]
on met en difficulté les communes alors
après il faudrait sonder les coeurs et
les reins pour savoir si c'est une
volonté délibérée ou pas mais en tout
cas on peut se poser légitimement la
question
sur la question indexation au revoyure
moi je préfère l'indexation
mais je veux dire ça peut dépendre des
sujets il y a des sujets où on ne peut
pas forcément indexer d'une année sur
l'autre et donc il peut y avoir quand
c'est quelque chose qui s'étale sur
plusieurs années plutôt une clause de
revoyure il y a j'allais dire les
marronniers ce qui revient chaque année
bon ce qui revient chaque année moi je
suis pour l'indexation
ce qui s'étale sur plusieurs années ça
peut être à ce moment-là si c'est par
exemple un transfert de compétences
c'est ce qui était évoqué qui se produit
sur plusieurs années ça peut être à ce
problème
parce que ça s'empile et c'est à la fin
de l'empilement qu'on peut j'allais dire
faire les comptes donc voilà mais en
temps normal quand c'est dans la
neualité c'est évidemment l'indexation
qui me paraît la meilleure formule parce
que c'est la moins injuste
la moins aléatoire
ensuite sur
CNN je veux dire
il vous a peut-être échappé qu'on a
commis un Lambert et moi une tribune
commune
ou nous demandons la fusion du CFL et du
cnen pour créer une autorité
administrative indépendante
et partout et d'ailleurs maintenant ça a
été repris ça à l'origine c'était une
initiative du président du cnen et du
président du CFF se trouve que avec à la
lombaire nous avons des relations nous
venons de famille politique différentes
mais nous avons à la fois de l'estime et
de l'amitié ce qui permet de travailler
en commun de bonnes manières c'est comme
ça la vie et c'est ce qu'on fait donc
nous nous concerons nous travaillons en
commun ce matin quand on débattait
j'avais aussi Antoine aubeck et
également vice-président du CNN je sais
je sais c'est pour ça que je le cite
oui oui
il vient de la Cour des comptes que
voulez-vous moi je ne suis qu'un modeste
prolétaire mais
bien non mais donc je veux dire nous
nous pensons que il est indispensable
qu'il y ait un lieu de convergence et
bon alors il faut changer un peu la
nature bien sûr des instances c'est à
dire c'est aussi la question qui a été
posée sur le caractère consultatif
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 95% uniquement
consultatif les 5% restants c'est
dans le cadre de la loi de finances
parfois nous sommes admis à répartir
répartir par exemple entre la DSR et au
sein de la DSR entre les villes centre
cette année on a on nous a d'ailleurs
par la loi de finance retirée une grande
possibilité de le faire puisque 60% de
la DSR a été automatiquement mis dans la
péréquation ce qui fait que nous
n'avions plus de 40% sur lequel nous
pouvions répartir
bien donc il peut y avoir aussi dans les
lois de finances j'allais dire un
dessaisissement d'une instance comme le
CFL de ces capacités il nous a été dit
que c'était exceptionnel et que ça ne se
reproduirait pas donc évidemment je
considère que ça vaut tout à fait
engagement pour l'avenir sur
[Musique]
les
politiques tarifaires des liaison des
taux je suis pour la déliaison bien
entendu aujourd'hui ça n'a plus aucun
sens déjà c'était discutable
antérieurement mais le grand argument
c'est on veut pas qu'on fasse payer les
entreprises alors qu'on ne ferait pas
payer les ménages mais aujourd'hui quand
on regarde les chiffres et ils ont été
publiés récemment par l'Observatoire des
finances et de la gestion publique
locale si vous allez sur le site vous
trouverez ça puisqu'on a regardé la
répartition entre les ménages et les
entreprises aujourd'hui ce sont
massivement les maisonnages qui bien
entendu participe au financement
on doit être alors je dis ça de mémoire
à 62% sur les ménages et à 38% sur le
monde économique voilà pour je crois
avoir j'espère rien oublier si les
politiques tarifaires évidemment ça
devient un vrai problème parce que on
aurait bien besoin de pouvoir monter nos
tarifs
et dans le même temps l'inflation nous
l'interdit quasiment
il y a une question de Luciennes
je vous inviterai
juste deux petites questions vous avez
parlé il y a quelques minutes de
l'indexation et de la revoyure mais
tenant compte de
la période actuelle où les choses
deviennent très peu maîtrisées notamment
sur la question du coût de l'énergie si
on était uniquement dans l'extation
est-ce que ça créerait pas en fait un
frein à l'évolution et à l'adaptation
quoi donc ce que ce serait pas plutôt
indexation et revoyure si nécessaire ça
c'était la première chose puis alors la
deuxième bon c'est un peu philosophique
c'est que parce que c'est quelque chose
qui plane dans cette commission depuis
le début qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
devenir des communes puisque vous l'avez
Fleuré quand même de façon et on en a
déjà parlé lé la dernière fois
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'intention
de
je dirais de l'État
dans dans ce domaine là surtout quand on
regarde dans le rétroviseur où on
s'aperçoit que petit à petit on rogne
tout ce qui concerne la les compétences
des communes et vous l'avez décrit et
quel est votre point de vue en termes de
prospective sur ce sur ce thème là
alors d'abord sur l'énergie si vous avez
5 minutes on bouge peut faire en moins
non mais au plus dans et c'est pour ne
pas faire attendre la cour après vous
tout à fait
en ce qui concerne l'énergie nous
réclamons le tarif réglementé pour
toutes les collectivités je me permets
de rappeler ça d'ailleurs ça viendra de
votre assemblée prochainement si je suis
bien informé oui oui je peux vous le
confirmer
ça serait curieux d'ailleurs que ça soit
moi qui confirme quelque chose ici c'est
une boutade et seulement mais
effectivement ça viendra le 6 avril
devant votre assemblée et j'ai
d'ailleurs rappelé à madame la Première
ministre que
c'est filet de sécurité
était des filets dans les mailles
étaient tellement larges
qu'elle n'attrapait pas grand chose
et que bien entendu il y aurait plus
besoin de ces oripos si le tarif
réglementé est mis en œuvre comme cela a
été déjà voté par l'Assemblée nationale
sourit à mon propos mais c'était pas
l'objet
c'était pas l'objet en tout cas bien
mais c'est un sujet essentiel par contre
le tarif réglementé je veux dire c'est
le seul moyen universel parce que sinon
après on bricole des choses moi je vais
vous dire honnêtement je ne sais pas si
ma ville sera éligible
ni pour 2022 ni pour 2023 et pareil pour
ma communauté j'ai posé la question à ma
direction départementale des finances
publiques qui a été hors d'état de me
répondre
puisqu'on a évidemment à représentant de
chacune des grandes directions donc de
la DG FIP
comment vous m'expliquez qu'on puisse
pas me répondre si je j'entre dans le
cadre ou pas
faut que je vois bon
donc on verra mais aujourd'hui donc
plutôt que au début on nous avait
annoncé je vous rappelle ce qu'on nous
parle de transparence donc la dernière
exemple on nous avait annoncé que il y
aurait 22 000 communes qui bénéficierait
en 2022 du filet de sécurité pas moi qui
ai donné les chiffres c'est à l'époque
comment il s'appelle déjà monsieur du
j'ai du mal à me souvenir de son nom
ça doit être du saute je crois bon je
suis comme ça des passages
où ma mémoire n'est pas tout à fait
fidèle elle donc
voilà 22000 aujourd'hui il y en a 4000
qui ont demandé à bénéficier d'avance et
on nous dit que certains devraient les
rembourser
non d'ailleurs pour ça que moi j'ai rien
demandé parce que si c'est pour me le
faire rembourser ça va encore accroître
ma difficulté bon dernier point
[Musique]
on cherche le sien pardon monsieur le
sénateur
le devenir des communes moi j'y crois
j'y crois en verre et contre tout
j'y crois parce que celui qui voudrait
s'attaquer à la suppression des communes
vous allez me pardonner cette référence
à l'actualité
mais ce qu'on connaît actuellement
serait de la petite bière à côté de ce
qui se produirait sur le terrain si
demain on disait à nos concitoyens
qu'ils n'ont plus de mairie dans
laquelle ils vont pouvoir aller pour
dire les difficultés qui sont celles de
leur quotidien donc moi je crois la
force des communes je crois la force des
communes
parce qu'elles incarnent la proximité
parce qu'elles incarnent la démocratie
et que toucher à cela
ça serait probablement l'une des actions
les plus
déstabilisantes pour la République et
pour la démocratie
j'avais des mots un peu plus forts qui
me venaient donc j'ai pris le temps de
trouver cette déstabilisation qui
stabilise mon propos
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
pour vos propos
clairs francs comme toujours tel que
vous êtes connu et reconnu par aux
élections successives à l'AMF
parfois contre vents et marais ou voilà
remarque comme celle-là comme ça au
passage aussi
donc je vous remercie vraiment
sincèrement on exclut pas de vous
réentendre notamment peut-être à plus
spécifiquement sur le CFL peut-être en
audition rapporteur je vous le dis aussi
très simplement en tant que de besoin
pour compléter ce dont on aura besoin à
la disposition
je pense que il y a une grande
convergence entre ce que vous pouvez
exprimer ce que au Sénat
préjugés de ce que nous proposera madame
la rapporteur sur vos vieux
je vous remercie merci président
d'être entendu par la représentation
nationale et de pouvoir dire les choses
c'est très agréable et vous proposons
notre mission et vont l'enrichir merci
donc à votre disposition merci beaucoup
président merci à vous merci à vous
chers collègues